amid the rubble from February's
devastating earthquakes Mehmet and
Nadeem try to make a living turkey has
economy has faltered in recent years but
despite the hardships many people's
loyalties have not shaken
president's act party appears to have
maintained its popularity in traditional
strongholds in southern provinces
I won't vote for anyone apart from the
ark party my grandfather and father were
members of the party
on Sunday The party that has governed
for two decades faces its toughest
election challenge yet there are 9
million voters in the earthquake
affected areas in the aftermath of one
of the worst disasters in modern Turkish
history many blame the government for
its initial slow response and accused it
of ignoring Building Safety standards
but not in erdogan's electoral base
I will sacrifice myself for him this
natural disaster was a test from God
erdogan did what he could and people
should be thankful I am even though I'm
living in a tent something
millions of people lost their homes
erdogan has focused much of his campaign
on promises to rebuild within a year but
here in hatai one of the worst hit
provinces many say they were and
continue to be ignored
floods after the quicks everyone there
was compensated but since the quicks
nothing was given to hatai they only
focus on those who vote for them
this is an opposition stronghold
in Turkey a voting behavior has a lot to
do with ideology political affiliation
and loyalties the state of the economy
and the handling of such a disaster will
have little impact on a decades-old
fault line
in simple terms there are secularists
and those who welcome a greater role for
Islam in public life and Turks not just
in these Quake devastated areas tend to
vote along party lines
Southern turkey